uh why don't we go next to john from
kentucky and see what's going on there
john what's up what's happening
hi david can you hear me yes are you
calling from an airplane
uh i'm calling from a car give me one
second okay no no it's not bad it's nice
it's nice ambient noise
okay well perfect um i was i was calling
because i had a question on uh
de-radicalizing leftists to be honest
okay
i i personally identify principally as a
socialist
but i've recognized in my time growing
up with this particular like uh
ideology that
reality does tend to skew liberal both
from the left wing and also the right
wing
like
for example um it's frustrating when i
talk to my socialist friends who want to
pretend like there's going to be a
violent revolution of the proletariat
yeah and
it i just have to look at them like are
you guys living in the same reality as
me
or similarly with the anti-vac stuff
people taking the big pharma
to
incredibly insane conclusions i was just
wondering if there was any way to
kind of engage with these sort of things
from a center perspective without coming
off as like a
like a shill for liberalism or deal sure
now just to be clear you're saying you
are a socialist but you want to talk
these peop talk to these folks more from
a centrist perspective is that what
you're saying
yeah principally i recognize that yeah i
do think it's a little bit messed up
that we have
more empty houses than we have homeless
people in america for example and that
is kind of terrible that's locked behind
a privatized system
that being said in our current system
it's probably a good thing that
landlords can evict people who aren't
taking care of their investment
i see i mean listen with the in in terms
of the people who are expecting or
waiting or hoping for a violent uprising
to you know to buy the proletariat i
think it makes sense to sort of talk
through
exactly how that would happen and
importantly the number of people that
might be killed or maimed in such a
revolution and see if they feel like
that the ends would justify the means
some might say yes some might say no
but i think it's good to just
have them walk you through all of the
steps if that makes sense now i've got
to ask are you driving a v8 with knobby
tires
um i'm actually just driving a good
old-fashioned 2014 ford fusion i have no
clue what kind of tires are on here wow
wow uh okay well listen uh john good
luck with the de-radicalization and
report back if you are able to
effectively do any of it
okay well thank you very much for your
time all right pleasure john from
kentucky
very strong first couple of calls not
great audio there on that second one but
we're going to deal with it